ciao sì lo so che ci siamo lasciati ma
vorrei che tu mi ascoltassi perché c'è
una cosa importante che ti devo dire no
non sono assolutamente arrabbiata anzi ho
capito ho capito che era destino che ci
lasciassimo e io lo so benissimo che non
è solo colpa tua perché entrambi abbiamo
le nostre colpe nonostante sia stato tu brutto stronzo
a lasciarmi perché é colpa tua é tutta colpa tua
ma io non voglio discutere
non voglio litigare no voglio soltanto
che tutto quello che c'è stato tra di
noi si trasformasse in una bella
amicizia
e visto che siamo amici sbloccami
perché tra amici non ci si tiene bloccati
eh e soprattutto dimmi con chi sta uscendo
perché non c'è motivo di bloccarmi se non
stai uscendo con nessuno eh
Mari??
quanto mi fa schifo
quando usciva con me diceva che la
odiava che era un'oca senza cervello e
adesso ci esce come esce con altre due
ragazze
ma dico é impazzito e tu perché non me
l'hai detto prima dimmi subito i nomi che
le devo andare a vedere con sto cesso?
ma fa schifo
ciao EDdo ciao Mari volevo presentarti il mio
nuovo fidanzato piacere molto
piacere si senti noi dobbiamo andare
dobbiamo sposarci ciao
e poi mi ha guardato e mi ha detto è
finita é tutta colpa mia se mi ha
lasciato
ho sbagliato tutto si era la mia vita io
non ne troverò mai piú uno come lui ed
è tutta colpa bene brava marina brava
allora come stai é un sacco che non ci si
vede cosa mi racconti cosa è successo
negli ultimi mesi
tutto bene anzi guarda prima che mi
dimentichi ti ho fatto un regalino
per il tuo compleanno anche se ci siamo
lasciati io tengo tantissimo a te sei
stato molto importante quindi ci tenevo
a farti avere questo regalo questo in
particolare è un libro molto carino e
molto romantico di Maryna che non so se
ti ricordi quella youtuber sai che guardavamo
i video insieme delle copie delle
fidanzate gelose che ti dicevo che ero io
ecco lei si in realtà l'ho conosciuta a una
festa ma lei si proprio la youtuber
è anche simpatica molto carina in realtà
si me l'ha regalato lei cioè
bellissimo regalo grazie
anzi siccome io l'ho già letto
bellissimo se vuoi tienilo leggilo tu
scusa lei ti ha regalato il libro cioè siete
amici quindi adesso sì qualcosa di più
ci frequentiamo in realtà volevo dirtelo
cioé non ti da fastidio veroa me no ma
figurati cioè comunque ci siamo
lasciati già da tre mesi é normale
rifarsi una vita
tr tr no guarda a posto così Mary tu hai sentito qualcosa amo ma
assolutamente no Mari allora io direi di
andare sará stato un moscerino amo ho
appena finito di stalkerarlo la situazione é
questa la biondina che non ci convinceva
effettivamente è in qualche foto sua ma
dietro come se la volesse nascondere e
qui gatta ci cova
sono andata a vedere il suo profilo ma la
stronzetta ovviamente ce l'ha privato
quindi visto che nella sua biografia
dice che vuole fare la modella io ho
utilizzato il mio vecchissimo account
fake quello dell'agenzia di moda per
contattarla e lei indovina un pó ha
abboccato crede veramente che la stia
invitando a un casting quindi adesso la
chiamerò e le estorcere
più informazioni possibili
ovviamente fingendomi un agente di moda
amo ne sono certa tempo tre o quattro
giorni e lui ritornerà da me Mari
ma vi siete lasciati da tre anni ma cosa
c'entra il grande Antonello dice che
certi amori fanno giri immensi ma poi
ritornano e lui ritornerà me lo sento
eccoti dov'eri é tutta la mattina che ti
aspetto ti sei dimenticato eh che mi dovevi
portare al centro commerciale noi due
andiamo tutte le domeniche al centro
commerciale Mari ma ci siamo lasciati da due anni
io e te non ci siamo mai lasciati mai
mettitelo bene in testa tu sei mio
adesso prendi la tua macchina e mi porti
al centro commerciale cosa guardi
di bello
cosa ci fai a casa mia ma come non
te l'ha detto tua mamma mi ha invitato per
pranzo potevo mica dire di no alla mia ex
suocera preferita lo sai che mi adora
e poi la tua sorellina questa sera ha un
appuntamento galante e ovviamente aveva
bisogno dell'assistenza psicologica
della sua consigliera preferita
lo sapevi che usciva con un nuovo ragazzo no
beh ovvio fatti due domande Mari? adesso tu mi
spieghi perché vai raccontare in giro
che mi hai lasciato tu perché è vero no
non è vero non è vero non dire cavolate
sono stata io a lasciarti io ho detto a
Sara sei mesi prima che tu mi lasciassi che ti
volevo lasciare quindi sono stata io
eh ma appunto tu l'hai detto a Sara ma
poi sono io che l'ho fatto non cambiare le
carte in tavola tu adesso vai dai tuoi
amici e dici che hai sbagliato che
invece sono stata io a lasciarti cavolo ma
perché devo dire una stupidata
Edo ci conosciamo come non mi
riconosci
così mi ferisci credo che tu abbia
sbagliato persona dopo tutto il tempo
che è passato dopo tutto il male che
mi hai fatto tu non ti ricordi di me eh io
non dimentico eh io non lo dimentico che
mi hai tradito con Emma della terza b eh
eravamo in gita in Valle d'Aosta e io ero lí
che piangevo mentre tu te la sbaciucchiavi
dentro la fabbrica della fontina
eh sì dove vai Mari ma raccontami un pó
tu dei tuoi ex dai ex sì un ex ce
l'avrai avuto un ex no
in realtà no non ho ex perché non
sono mai stata fidanzata perché sono
single dalla nascita non me lo fare pesare
ei ciao ma che ci fai qui Marina cosa ci fai
tu scusami ci abito lo sai benissimo ah si
me l'ero dimenticato comunque sono venuta qui a
fare un giretto senti perché non ci
prendiamo un bel caffè é da tanto che non
chiacchieriamo insomma guarda sono in
ritardo aspetto una persona chi quale
delle diciassette ragazze che hai
iniziato a seguire dopo che ci siamo
lasciati eh Emma la biondina o Jasmine
che hai conosciuto in discoteca quando stavi ancora
con me eh o quella col proprio verificato
che si finge modella chi chi chi
quella che quale quale maledetto eccoci qui
maryners siamo arrivati alla fine del
video io vi ricordo che cuore corazza il
mio primo romanzo lo trovate in tutte
le librerie e su tutte le piattaforme
digitali
inoltre ricordatevi di seguirmi su
instagram perché comunicherò lì tutte le
date dei firmacopie
spero tantissimo che il video vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando fatemi sapere qui
sotto a quali di queste tipologie
appartenete e soprattutto se non l'avete
ancora fatto iscrivetevi al canale e
attivate la campanella vicino al tasto
d'iscrizione per rimanere sempre
aggiornati sui miei video io vi mando un
bacione enorme e ci vediamo al prossimo
video adoro